Sid is experimenting with a piece of
sandpaper and some would he try scraping
the piece of sandpaper over the wood in
different ways to see how much is
scraped off the thickness of wood
scraped off in millimeters as a function
of the speed of the sandpaper in meters
per second T of V so this is the
thickness scraped off so that's how much
those sorts of thickness or how much is
scraped off and it is a function of
speed and actually since they're 1
they're using V and also they're getting
negative value so we care about the
direction I'll even call that it's
actually the velocity so this is the how
much is scraped off as a function of
velocity it's shown below and so if the
velocity is greater than zero that means
that the sandpaper is moving to the
right that makes sense the standard
convention and if the velocity is less
than 0 means the sandpaper is moving to
the left fair enough
the function is even what is the func
what is the significance of the evenness
of this function well the fact that it's
even means that T of V is equal to T of
negative V so that tells us that if we
if our velocity is 8 is if our velocity
is 8 meters per second to the left we're
going to get as much scraped off as if
we go 8 millimeters per second to the
right and we see that right over here so
that is equal to that if we go at 6
meters per second to the left we're
going to get just as much scraped off as
we go 6 millimeters 6 meters per second
these are in meters per second to the
right so these two are going to be the
same so it's really telling us and we
could say do it for 4 meters per second
and negative 4 is it doesn't matter if
we go to the left or the right what
really matters is is e is the magnitude
of the velocity or the the absolute
value of it but doesn't matter if we're
going to the left or the right whether
we're going to the left or the right for
a given for given magnitude of velocity
we are going to get the same amount
scraped off now let's see which of these
choices are consistent with what I just
said moving the sandpaper faster scrapes
off more wood
well that's true we see as the speed
increases where the magnitude of the
speed increases we scrape off more wood
as the magnitude of the speed this
negative eight you might say hey that's
lower than negative two but the
magnitude is larger we're going eight
meters per second to the left and we're
scraping off more so this is this is
this is a true statement but it's not
the significant that it's not the
significance of the evenness of the
function this could have been true even
if this was a seven but then this
function would no longer be even the
piece of wood is six millimeters thick
well this doesn't really we actually
don't get any of that from the function
moving the sandpaper to the right has
the same effect as moving it to the left
well that seems pretty close to what I
had said earlier that for a given speed
to the right or to the left we get the
same amount that is taken off of the
piece of sandpaper or the piece of wood
so this looks like our answer
keeping the sandpaper still doesn't
scrape off any wood well that is true
but once again is not the significance
of the evenness of this function